aoc
took a little vacation and she's in hot
trouble because of it aoc
went down she left the tyrannical state
of new york her own state and she went
down to the free state of florida
good old desantis land where you can do
what you want and breed the fresh air
and have a nice time
so she goes down to florida
while her constituents are dealing with
spike and covid and
spiking crime because of
the bad policies that aoc in part is is
supporting
and a spike in all sorts of misery in
new york i did go to new york briefly
over christmas not looking great city
has seen better days let's put it that
way
so she goes she abandons them she goes
to florida on vacation i don't really
begrudge her her vacation but it's a bad
look if you're going to make fun of ted
cruz for going to mexico and you're
going to castigate him and yell at him
over that then what's good for the goose
is good for the gander aoc and aoc was
leading that charge screaming at ted
cruz because he went to a sunny place
as there was
as there were problems in his own state
well aoc did exactly the same thing and
so she got caught and she's a big old
hypocrite as we all know
and her response
was so typical
she said the only reason people were
criticizing her
is because
they want to date her
that republican men
really want to date her and she won't
she won't date them
and so
they're criticizing her
i saw someone on twitter over the
weekend asked if uh if you had a choice
would you rather date aoc
or be banished to saint helena that's
the island that they banished napoleon
to and that i suggest we banish dr fauci
to
which would you would you rather be
banished to a far-flung island or date
aoc
and it was observed by some people that
you're only going to get peace and quiet
in one of those
situations
so choose carefully
uh
here's a aoc's exact words quote if
republicans are mad they can't date me
they can just say that instead of
projecting their sexual frustrations
onto my boyfriend's feet you creepy
weirdos starting to get old ignoring the
very obvious strange and deranged sexual
frustrations that underpin the
republican fixation on me women and lgbt
plus people in general
hold on the sexual frustrations
so
you're if you're critical of aoc it's
because you want to date her and if
you're critical of say the lgbt movement
it's because you want to date
the dudes
so you're you you must be very sexually
confused if you it's you're really you
want to date the transsexuals and the
homosexuals and aoc you're you want to
date all these people you can't make up
your mind
and none of your criticisms are
legitimate
she says these people clearly need
therapy they won't do it they use
politics as their outlet instead it's
really weird
this is the same sort of thing that aoc
said about the fake insurrection on
january 6 you know the worst the
greatest threat ever ever against
america ever in history
she said that she was almost raped
on january 6th
she was almost raped by the
insurrectionists
and then we found out actually she
wasn't even in the capitol she was in
her office building which was a
considerable distance from the capitol
and the insurrectionists quote unquote
didn't get anywhere near her office
actually was just a cop who was showing
up there just to make sure she was safe
just to protect her
and
the
thought that she was about to be raped
was entirely in her own delusion it was
entirely in her own head this woman
i want to be really polite about this i
don't want to i don't want to be rude
this woman has an extremely inflated
sense of her own
attractiveness she
she's not
i i don't know i'm just speaking for
myself i don't want to date aoc
i do not now nor have i ever wanted to
date aoc i don't know any republican who
wants to date aoc i don't want to be
rude and say mean things about a woman's
appearance or
personality or but
lady
you
she needs a reality check and i suppose
that's true in many areas
philosophically ideologically
politically
the reason that her comment is
interesting is not because of just how
juvenile it is and how divorced from
reality it is but because it actually is
part of the kind of broader
left-wing reaction to conservative
criticism which is to reject the
legitimacy of any criticism of their
political agenda and to pathologize all
of it
the left
always dismiss dismisses conservative
criticism of their agenda as the result
of some
usually sexual mental illness
some kind of pathology lionel trilling
said this back in the 20th century
he said that there is no conservative
intellectual movement in america
it's just a series of irritable mental
gestures
the reason conservatives
uh perhaps object to redefining marriage
or our sexual ethic is not because they
recognize that the human body has a
nature
that our sp our soul and our body have
something to do with one another that
the body has a purpose and that there is
a fundamental political building block
of society such as the family we could
go on and on and on it's not because of
any reasonable arguments
it's because
they're foes
you know they're haters
they're ists
the sexists and the racists and the
phobes and that's why it's all
irrational
and so what they need is not a vigorous
debate
to determine how we want to proceed as a
society what they need is not
deliberation and persuasion what they
need is therapy
what they need is to go
be put on some drugs
or what they need is to go
just be brainwashed they need or they
need to be
ostracized from society i'm glad you
like that clip i'm glad that in this new
year
still christmas and this wonderful
christmas season you like that clip
go check out the whole show by ringing
the bell subscribing heading on over to
your favorite audio podcast platform
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcasts type
in the michael knowles show it's gonna
take two seconds
subscribe that's a christmas present to
yourself
leave a five-star review maybe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]